chaillot et maintenant on va parler
d'eux
bon vous dites je n'ai pas voulu être
acteur pour de bonnes raisons j'ai voulu
être acteur pour les paillettes un fruit
frais qu'au début à 13 ans vous avez
voulu être acteur parce que vous
accompagnez votre père georges wilson
dans les premières au départ c'était
juste l'amour du spectacle plus belle
avant s'agit j'espère qu'il ya jean
gueule triste vraiment poignant parce
que rsa quand on m'a demandé à l'école
si je voulais être comédien j'ai dis
surtout pas surtout pas parce qu'un
comédien c'est quelqu'un qui ait jamais
à la maison
ouais et donc ça c'était c'était
vraiment surtout ça le truc le cauchemar
c'était un comédien c'est forcément
quelqu'un qui était tellement obsédé par
son travail et que toute façon il était
il avait le temps pour rien d'autre
c'est vrai que votre père vous ne voyez
pas beaucoup avaient été levés la
campagne non mais il était là il était
quand même ils regardent l'émission il
faut pas que je dise déchets et nous
avons des rapports forcés
nous avons des rapports mais ils sont
treize à maurice la campagne non non non
bien alors votre père donc justement
c'est georges wilson qui était
saxophoniste c'est des gens ne savent
pas ils croient qu'il a toujours été
comédien a pris l'été acteur puis
directeur du tnp évidemment et votre
prénom lambert vient de la pièce de
claudel oui alors bottemer ben elle
vient comme lui d'ailleurs comme georges
wilson d'un milieu assez modeste était
très belle votre mère elle est à elle
voulait le mannequin elle voulait de
comédienne mais 6 mai puis à 17 ans elle
a rencontré votre père est devenu femme
au foyer parce que lui comme il avait
été orphelin il voulait recréer une
cellule familiale
oui c'est vrai que on oublie tout le
temps quand on apparaît dans le métier
que lui public imagine que tout est fait
d' avance pour vous parce que c'est
voilà vous êtes déjà dans le faste des
seins que vous venez d'un d'un milieu
difficile et c est pour mon père c'est
vrai qu'être acteur comme pour beaucoup
d'acteurs maintenant c'est une vengeance
contre le monde une vengeance contre
l'injustice contre la misère contre la
guerre contre tous alors effectivement
moi j'arrive plus tard plus protégés
mais néanmoins avec mes souffrances
alors vous voyez souvenir c'est à
chaillot au palais des papes d'avignon
aussi et vous dites mon père incarné des
personnages de roy qui régnait sur des
sur des châteaux et j'avais le sentiment
que ces châteaux étaient à nous mais
surtout chaillou mois-ci pendant des
années quand on passait devant le
trocadéro palais de chaillot est belle
mais que c'était notre château et qui en
erythrée oui bah oui parce que forcément
il était en plus endroits à l'intérieur
et puis tout le monde faisait un petit
peu là elle a light pro fait déchanter à
l'école vous mentiez vous disiez que
vous aviez passer des week-ends à new
york vous aviez des rolls tout ça j'ai
passé longtemps dans ma vie a menti
wayne simmonds
j'avais une sorte de fantasme du
effectivement de la fast
c'est curieux parce qu'en plus on
manquait de rien vraiment au moment où
moi je suis arrivé finalement et ouais
je pensais que notre vie ne suffisait
pas et c'est un moteur très régulier
chez les acteurs effectivement il faut
on veut devenir prince
les chocs artistique c'est à l'âge de 7
ans c'est au palais des papes avec votre
mère qui me couverture sur les genoux
les options du mistral
et puis vous êtes tombés raconte
vachement je raconte
vous tombez amoureux delaunay bellon
dans l'illusion comique de corneille ce
coup ci et puis vous tombez complètement
amoureuse andy je veux la revoir le
lendemain je veux la revoir de la revoir
et le lendemain vous les découvrez
durant les répétitions
pas maquillée transpirant au soleil dans
la cour du palais des papes
et là c'est une tragédie peau mais ce
que je demande où elle est je l'avais
ouais elle était dans le costume jeudi
mais enfin quand on prend des mois la
bonne quoi et là je crois que de toute
façon le vide et le mythe du théâtre
mais tombée d'un coup à 7 ans sur les
épaules mais c'est trop tôt ouais c'est
un peu trop tourner ça vous êtes cassé
l'arrêt recul 4 c'est aussi le site vie
des femmes tout ça je me suis amusé à
calais le je ne suis pas venu vous
voulez vous allongez plus besoin de
s'allonger un petit vent catherine
sûrement ici alors très aisément si vous
n'êtes pas entré dans la profession par
votre père mais par votre prof de
français
et puis après votre père vous a donné
deux petits rôles mais quand il a vu que
c'était sérieux
justement il a dit je suis pas d'accord
parce que t'as pas assez souffert
justement le vide avait eu effectivement
cette vengeance de l'orphelin la guerre
alain georges
il a dit tu n'as pas assez ou trop
solaire
voilà la musique fait des révélations
absolument propulsif cd carrément autour
d'une conversation super prix néanmoins
trop mais il y avait un livre aux
oreilles je pense que c'était surtout
pour me mettre en garde contre et je
continue à vouloir mettre en garde moi
même les générations de gens qui veulent
faire ce métier c'est vrai qu'on en
prend plein la gueule c'est vrai qu' on
est toujours en première ligne critiqué
sur non pas un travail qu'ont fourni
mais sur des qualités soin de sa chair
soit 2,2 de son caractère et du coup on
n'a aucune protection on est
perpétuellement jugé sur qui on est et
c'est horriblement aurait dit ça va là
que votre père vous disent pas en même
temps c'est vrai il avait un peu raison
vous un essai d'acteurs ça se construit
sur la souffrance intrus sur la
vengeance plus que est plus sympa j'ai
fait les autres je pense que parfois
j'avais passé mois de moteurs de vous
mais
j'ai trouvé en cours de route ouais ce
moteur là alors c'est un tel désir de
faire du théâtre du cinéma de jouer que
vous partez à londres au drama center et
ses quelque temps plus tard fait votre
premier film ça c'est un coup de bol
énorme vraiment de la chance il fait
giulia de fred zinnemann et jane fonda
et votre les jours de tournage vous
retrouver comme ça nez à nez avec le le
regard bleu turquoise de jane fonda et
c'est vrai nom même et c'est génial
parce que j'ai plus rien à dire est ce
que j'allais dire mais oui justement ça
et sanguins son regard bleu turquoise
une relation alors vous jouiez le rôle
de quelqu'un qui était mort de peur et
vous étiez mort de peur j'ai tracé pour
la peur de passer pour un génie aux yeux
dilma est effectivement cinq ans plus
tard il m'a proposé un des rôles
principaux de son film qui s'appelait
cinq jours ce printemps là aux côtés de
sean connery parce qu'il avait trouvé
que j'avais été tellement incroyable
dans cette scène j'étais simplement je
vraiment faisait dans mon pantalon
il a été il a été vraiment émerveillé
mais la peur on pourra en parler parce
que c'est vrai que moi j'ai quand
j'étais petit je cherchais cette
sensation en permanence je voulais avoir
peur dans les manèges etc et
curieusement j'ai la peur elle est
présente et c'est une c'est une vraie
drogue etc supporte pas et en même temps
on a peur quand on aimerait vous par
exemple c'est agréable d'avoir peur
justement c'est la volupté de la peur
vous aimez avoir peur
oui c'est vrai que c'est un moteur
formidable bilan douze mille personnes
prenant les wem et c'est c'est le cette
peur a été compensée par ya enfin en
tout cas moi je ressens deux choses
c'est que j'ai envie un peu de me barrer
en courant mais je crois que je donnerai
ma place à personne rien au monde je me
disais à ce que je me dis que j'ai très
très peur je me dis j'imagine un copain
qui me disent on veut se fait rien
laisse tomber vient à temps matt et
conques
voilà donc cinq jours ce printemps-là de
fred zinnemann cinq ans après
effectivement giuly a hélas vous faites
un suisse une copine qui vous dit
d'aller au casting déguisé en suisse oui
surtout vie on était au mois de juin il
fait super chaud à paris chez riverains
qui n'en tuer comme maintenant et et on
m'a demandé quel temps il vit à paris j
il est inné chez neiges on est alors en
droit dans les yeux et j'ai senti que
c'était à 7 secondes que j'ai eu le rôle
deux fois de suite
ouais à l'exil man quelques jours plus
tard vous retrouvez face à sean connery
et là vous avez sentiment d'usurper voie
possible pour s'apercevoir que je mérite
pas d'être là bas comme maintenant elle
maintenant dans cette émission comme
maintenant sur scène à chaque moment à
un moment donné on se dit mais ils vont
bien découvrir que on est on concède pas
du tout de quoi on parle on est pas mais
ils en gagnent ils vont bien découvrir
alors particulièrement dans cette espèce
de montagnes écossaises qui vous qui
vous toise comme ça et qui fait aucun
effort que le regard oui bien avec
l'équipe et avec l'école des sorciers et
et ça a été cinq mois mais vraiment
serré les dents je pleurais tous les
soirs dans mon hôtel parce que j'en
prenais plein poids alors ensuite vous
retourner en france va vous commencez
votre carrière cinématographique avec la
boum 2 avec téchiné avec brooke à la
vouivre film de georges wilson est là
allez
et là j'ai mis ça mais la plainte des 10
de vous j'en ai trouvé plein il y en a
des très bons mots chantés très bien
mais les classiques et tout c'est fou ça
nous a pris à un moment dire faisait du
cinéma deux films exil man la boum 2
tout ça et puis d'un coup deux parties
je crois que c'est cette fibre familiale
saxophoniste mon frère est un saxophone
et je pense que d'une certaine façon
peut-être que au lieu d'être acteur
j'aurais dû faire de la musique etc et
même façon de faire d'amis s'est arrêté
le choix du champ ouais mais moi j'aime
scier exposé sans assez de préparation
d'être venue d'un cinéma ce moment là
non mais j'avais jamais arrêter le
cinéma oui mais là sérieusement bien
parce qu'en plus c'est ce truc en france
qu'est que si on chante c'est que
forcément votre carrière et va très bien
et donc c'est une à ses dépens
la carrière va très bien c'est un one
shot
je venais une mais bien mais bien mais
malinké joyau mais voilà on va faire
lors de faire un petit test
alessi
[ __ ] parce que ça se danse forcément
moins bien donc le 13 juin
qu'est ce qui se passe et 13 juin le 13
juin il ya la sortie de la comédie hs
avec dieudonné et françois berléand
la voie est toute la combe du fait de la
promo alors dont lambert wilson quand
vous étiez petit vous croyez que vous
étiez un prince et votre père un roi bon
on va voir ce à quoi vous croyez
aujourd'hui on va faire l'interview
croyances